it so happens that there's a Wikipedia
page about me
as I've learned recently and uh the
first thought I had when I saw that was
uh surely I am not notable enough so I
was very surprised and grateful that
such a page could exist and actually
just allow me to say thank you to all
the incredible people that are part of
creating and maintaining Wikipedia it's
my favorite website on the internet the
collection of articles that Wikipedia
has created it's just incredible uh
we'll talk about the various details of
that but
the the love and care that goes into
creating Pages for individuals for a big
pen for all this kind of stuff is just
it's just really incredible so I just
felt the love when I when I saw that
page but I also felt just because I do
this podcast and I just through this
podcast gotten to know a few individuals
that are quite controversial I've gotten
to be on the receiving end of something
quite
to me as a person who loves other human
beings I've gone to be at the receiving
end of some kind of attacks through the
Wikipedia form like you said when you
look at Living individuals it can be
quite hurtful the little details of
information
um and because I've become friends with
Elon Musk
and have interviewed him but I've also
interviewed people on the left uh far
left people on the right some people
would say far right and so now you take
a step you put your toe into the cold
pool of politics and the shark emerges
from the dubs and pulls you right in a
boiling hot pool of politics I guess
it's it's hot and so I got to experience
some of that uh I think
what you also realize is
um there has to be for Wikipedia kind of
credible sources verifiable sources
and there's a dance there because some
of the sources are uh pieces of
Journalism and of course journalism
operates under its own complicated
incentives such that people can write
articles that are not factual or
um are cherry-picking all the flaws they
can have in a journalistic for sure and
those can be used as as sources it's
like they dance hand in hand and so
um for me sadly enough there was a
really kind of concerted attack to say
that I was never at MIT I never did
anything in MIT just to clarify I am a
research scientist at MIT I have been
there since 2015 I'm there today I'm at
a prestigious amazing laboratory called
lids and I hope to be there for a long
time and work on AI robotics machine
learning there's a lot of incredible
people there and by the way MIT has been
very kind to defend me unlike Wikipedia
says it is not an unpaid position
there was no controversy it was all very
uh calm and happy and Almost Boring
research that I've been doing there and
the other thing because I am half
Ukrainian half Russian and I've traveled
to Ukraine and I will travel to Ukraine
again
uh and I will travel to Russia for some
very difficult conversations uh my
heart's been broken by this War I have
family in both places it's been a really
difficult time
but the little
battle about the biography there also
starts becoming important for the first
time uh for me I also want to clarify
sort of personally I use this
opportunity of some inaccuracies there
my father was not born in Chicago Russia
he was born in Kiev Ukraine
I was born in Chicago
which is a town not in Russia there is a
town like called that in Russia but
there's another town in Tajikistan which
is a Former Republic of the Soviet Union
it is that town is now called
b-u-s-t-o-n buston
which is funny because we're now in
Austin and Allison in Boston it seems
like my whole life is surrounded by
these kinds of towns so I was born in
Tajikistan and the rest of the biography
is interesting but my family is very
evenly distributed between their Origins
and where they grew up between Ukraine
and Russia which is as a whole beautiful
complexity to this whole thing so I want
to just correct that it's like the
fascinating thing about Wikipedia
is in some sense those little details
don't matter
but in another sense what I felt when I
saw a Wikipedia page about me or anybody
I know is is there's this beautiful kind
of saving that this person existed
like a community that notices you it
says like uh like a little you see like
a like a butterfly that floats and
you're like huh that it's not just any
butterflies that one I like that one or
you see a puppy or something or uh or
it's this big pen this one I remember
this one as the scratch and you get
noticed in that way and that I know
that's a beautiful thing and it's
I mean maybe it's very silly of me and
naive but I feel like Wikipedia in terms
of individuals is an opportunity to
celebrate
people to celebrate ideas for sure and
not a battleground of attacks of the
kind of stuff we might see on on Twitter
like the mockery the derision this kind
of stuff for sure and of course you
don't want to cherry pick all of us have
flaws and so on but it just feels like
um to highlight a controversy of some
sort when that doesn't at all represent
the entirety of the human in most cases
yeah it's sad yeah yeah yeah so there's
a few things uh to unpack and all that
um so first one of the things I find
really always find very interesting is
you know your status with MIT okay
that's that's upsetting and it's an
argument and can be sorted out
but then what's interesting is you you
gave as much time to that which is
actually important and relevant to your
career and so on to also where your
father was born which most people would
hardly notice but is really meaningful
to you and I find that a lot when I talk
to people over a biography in Wikipedia
is they're often is annoyed by a tiny
error that no one's going to notice like
this town in Tajikistan yes got a new
name and so on like nobody even knows
what that means or whatever but it can
be super important
um and so that's that's one of the
reasons you know for biographies we we
say like human dignity really matters
um and so you know some of the things
have to do with and this is this is a
common debate that goes on in Wikipedia
is what we call undue weight so I give
I'll give an example
um
there was a article I stumbled across
many years ago about you know the mayor
I know he wasn't a mayor he was a city
council member of I think it was Peoria
Illinois but some small town in in the
Midwest and the entry you know he's been
on the city council for 30 years or
whatever he's pretty I mean frankly
pretty boring guy and seems like a good
local city politician but in this very
short biography there was a whole
paragraph a long paragraph about his son
being arrested for DUI
and it was clearly undue weight it's
like what has this got to do with this
guy if it even deserves a mention it
wasn't even clear
had he done anything hypocritical had he
done himself anything wrong even was his
son his son got a DUI that's never great
but it happens to people and it doesn't
seem like a massive Scandal for your dad
so of course I just took that out
immediately this is a long long time ago
and that's the sort of thing where uh
you know we have to really think about
in a biography and about controversies
to say is this a real controversy so in
general like one of the things we we
tend to say is like any section so if
there's a biography and there's a
section called controversies that's
actually poor practice because it just
invites people to say oh I want to work
on this entry let's see there's seven
sections oh this one's quite short can I
add something right go out and find some
more controversies that's nonsense right
and in general putting it separate from
everything else kind of makes it seem
worse and also doesn't put it in the
right context whereas if it's sort of a
life flow and there is a controversy
there's always potential controversy for
anyone uh it should just be sort of
worked into the overall article because
then it doesn't become a Temptation you
can contextualize appropriately and so
forth so that's you know
um
uh uh that's you know part of the whole
process but I think for me one of the
most important things is is what I call
Community Health so yeah are we going to
get it wrong sometimes yeah of course
we're humans and doing good quality you
know sort of reference material is hard
the real question is how do people react
you know to a criticism or a complaint
or a concern and if the reaction is
defensiveness or combativeness back or
if someone's really sort of in there
being aggressive
um and in the wrong
like no no no hold on we've got to do
this the right way you got to say okay
hold on you know are there good sources
is this contextualized appropriately is
it even important enough to mention
um what does it mean uh you know and
sometimes one of the the areas where I
do think there is a very complicated
flaw and and you've alluded to it a
little bit but it's like we know the
media is deeply flawed we know that
journalism uh can go wrong and I would
say particularly in the last whatever 15
years we've seen a real decimation of
local media local newspapers uh we've
seen a real rise in Click bait headlines
and sort of eager focus on anything that
might be controversial we've always had
that with us of course there's always
been tabloid newspapers
but that makes it a little bit more
challenging to say okay how do we how do
we sort things out
um when we have a pretty good sense that
that not every source is valid so as an
example
um
a few years ago it's been quite a while
now
um we deprecated uh the mail online as a
source
um and the mail online you know the
digital arm of the Daily Mail it's a
tabloid it it's not completely you know
it's not fake news but it does tend to
run very hyped up stories they they
really love to attack people and go on
the attack for political reasons and so
on and it just isn't great and so by
saying deprecated and I think some
people say oh you ban The Daily Mail no
we didn't ban it as a source we just
said look it's probably not a great
source right you should probably look
for a better source so certainly you
know if the daily mail runs a headline
saying
um new cure for cancer it's like you
know probably there's more serious
sources than a tabloid newspaper so you
know in an article about lung cancer you
probably wouldn't cite the Daily Mail
that's kind of ridiculous but also for
celebrities and and so forth to sort of
they do cover celebrity gossip a lot but
they also tend to have vendettas and so
forth and you really have to step back
and go is this really encyclopedic or is
this just the daylight mail going on
around and some of that requires a great
Community Health like I mean it requires
massive Community Health even for me for
stuff I've seen as kind of if actually
iffy about people I know things I know
about myself I still feel
like a a love for knowledge emanating
from the article like in LA like I feel
the community health so I will take all
slight inaccuracies I would I I would I
love it because that means there's
people for the most part I feel of
respect and love in this search for
knowledge like sometimes because I also
love stock overflow stock exchange for
programming related things and they can
get a little cranky sometimes to a
degree where it's like
it's not as like you could see you can
feel the Dynamics of the health of the
particular Community yeah and and
sub-communities too like a particularly
c-sharp or Java or python or whatever
like there's little like communities
that emerge you can feel the levels of
toxicity because a little bit of
strictness is good but a little too much
is bad yeah because of the defensiveness
because when somebody writes an answer
and then somebody else kind of says well
modify it and get defensive and there's
this uh tension that's not conducive to
like uh improving towards a more
truthful depiction of like what with
that topic yeah a great example that I
really loved uh this morning that I saw
someone left a note on my user talk page
in English Wikipedia saying it was quite
a dramatic headline thing uh racist hook
on front page so we have on the front
page of Wikipedia we have a little
section called did you know it's just
little tidbits and foxes things people
find interesting and there's a whole
process for how things get there
and the one that somebody was raising a
question about was it was comparing a
very well-known uh U.S football player
black uh there was a quote from another
famous sport person uh comparing him to
a Lamborghini clearly a compliment uh
and so somebody said actually here's a
study here's some interesting
information about how black sports
people are far more often compared to
inanimate objects and given that kind of
analogy and I think it's demeaning to
compare a person to a car
um Etc but they said I'm not I'm not
pulling I'm not deleting it I'm not
removing it I just want to raise the
question and then there's this really
interesting conversation that goes on
where I think the general consensus was
you know what this isn't like
like the alarming headline racist thing
on the front page Wikipedia that sounds
holy moly that sounds bad but it's sort
of like um actually yeah this this
probably isn't the sort of analogy that
we think is great and so we should
probably think about how to improve our
language and not not compare Sports
people to inanimate objects and
particularly be aware of
certain racial sensitivities that there
might be around that sort of thing if
there is a disparity in the media of how
people are called and I just thought you
know what nothing for me to weigh in on
here this is a good conversation like
nobody's saying you know people should
be banned if if they refer to what was
his name the fridge Refrigerator Perry
the you know very famous comparison to
an inanimate object of a Chicago Bears
player many years ago but they're just
saying hey let's be careful about
analogies that we just pick up from the
media I said yeah you know that's good
on the sort of uh deprecation of news
sources really interesting because I
think what you're saying is ultimately
you want to make a article by article
decision kind of use your own judgment
and it's such a subtle thing because uh
the
there's just a lot of hit pieces written
about individuals like myself for
example That masquerade as
kind of an objective thorough
exploration of a human being it's
fascinating to watch because controversy
and hit Pieces Just get more clicks oh
yeah this is I I guess as a Wikipedia
contributor
you start to deeply become aware of that
and start to have a sense like a radar
of Click bait versus truth like to to
pick out the truth from the clickbaity
type language oh yeah I mean it's it's
really important and you know we talk a
lot about weasel words
um you know and
um you know actually I'm sure we'll end
up talking about
but just to quickly mention in this area
I think one of the potentially powerful
tools
um
well because it is quite good at this
I've played around with and practiced it
quite a lot but Chad gbt4 is is really
quite able to to take a passage
and
uh
point out potentially biased terms to
rewrite it to be more neutral now it is
a bit uh anadine and it's a bit you know
cliched so sometimes it just takes the
spirit out of something that's actually
not bad it's just like you know poetic
language and you're like well okay
that's not actually helping but in many
cases I think that sort of thing is
quite interesting and I'm also
interested in
um you know
can you imagine where you you
feed in a Wikipedia entry and all the
sources
and you say
help me find anything in the article
that is not accurately reflecting what's
in the sources and that doesn't have to
be perfect it only has to be good enough
to be useful to community so if if it
scans an article and all the sources and
you say oh it came back with
10 suggestions and seven of them were
decent and three of them it just didn't
understand well actually that's probably
worth my time to do and it can help us
um you know really
um more quickly get good people to sort
of review obscure entries uh and things
like that so just as a small aside on
that and we'll probably talk about
language models a little bit uh or a lot
more but one of the Articles uh one of
the hit pieces about me
uh the journalist actually was very
straightforward and honest about having
used GPT to write part of the article oh
interesting and then finding that it
made an error and apologized for the
error the gpt4 generated which has this
kind of interesting Loop which is the
articles are used to write Wikipedia
Pages GPT is trained on Wikipedia and
then there's like this um
interesting
Loop where the weasel words and the
nuances can get lost or can uh propagate
even though they're not ground in
reality uh somehow in the generation of
the language model new truths can be
created and kind of linger yeah there's
a famous webcomic that's titled
cytogenesis which is about how
something an errors in Wikipedia and
there's no source for it but then a lazy
journalist reads it and writes The
Source yeah and then some helpful
wikipedian spots that it has no Source
finds the source and adds it to
Wikipedia and voila magic this happened
to me once it it uh well it nearly
happened
um there was this I mean it was really
brief I went back and researched it I'm
like this is really odd so biography
magazine which is a magazine published
by the biography TV channel
um how to post a profile of me and it
said
uh in his spare time I'm not quoting
exactly it's been many years but in his
spare time he enjoys playing chess with
friends I thought wow that sounds great
like I would like to be that guy but
actually I mean I play chess with my
kids sometimes but no I'm not it's not a
hobby of mine
and
uh I was like where did they get that
and I contacted the magazine said
where'd that come from they said oh it
was in Wikipedia I looked in the history
there had been vandalism of Wikipedia
which was not you know it's not damaging
it's just false so and it had already
been removed but then I thought oh gosh
well I better mention this to people
because otherwise it's somebody's going
to read that and they're going to add it
the entry and it's going to take on a
life of its own and then sometimes I
wonder if it has because I've been I was
invited a few years ago to do the
ceremonial first move in the World Chess
Championship and I thought I wonder if
they think I'm a really big chess
Enthusiast because they read this
biography magazine article so but that
that problem uh when we think about
large language models and the ability to
quickly generate very plausible but not
true content I think it's something that
there's going to be a lot of ShakeOut a
lot of implications of that what would
be hilarious is because of the social
pressure of Wikipedia and the momentum
you would actually start playing a lot
more chess just not only the articles
are written
um based on Wikipedia but your own life
trajectory changes because just to make
it more convenient
yeah aspire to Aspire to yes my
aspirational